Hey Charles.
>> Hey Michael.
>> So like I get to lecture near you today.
>> Yes you do. I can even see you.
>> This is, this is crazy. I sort of don't
have my regular pad. This makes me a little uncomfortable.
>> But you look very dashing in your nice blue suit.
>> Thanks. We're going to record some live action stuff today.
>> Mm.
>> [LAUGH] All right so. Do you remember
last time we were talking about Bayesian learning?
>> I do, because I led that.
>> Right. Good point.
And so one of the questions that I asked as a follow-up was, these
quantities, these probabilistic quantities that we're working
with. Is there's anything that we need to
know about how to represent and reason with them. And you said that I should
look into it. Yeah, because I, I just, I yeah you should look into it.
>> So I did. So, and it's cool. And so
I figured it would be fun to tell you about it.
>> Okay, well I look forward to it.
>> Thanks! And also I want to point out, we're
using a different color scheme today. Isn't that a nice blue?
>> It is a nice blue, its sort
of a relaxing blue. As opposed to that blue blue that we used before.
>> It's like Cerulean... Is it?
>> No.
>> It's more like periwinkle.
>> No, it's definitely not periwinkle.
>> Oh you're right, it's not periwinkle. Periwinkle's a
>> Navy.
>> No, it's too light to be navy.
>> All right, so so good, so right. It turns out that there's this concept
called Bayesian Networks, which is this wonderful
representation for representing and manipulating probabilistic quantities over
complex spaces. And so it fits in really well
with the stuff you were talking about last time.